すごい隠れている秘密のものでもないんです
堂々と活動している働きなんですね
それで私はこのすごいわかりやすい定義をした覚えがあるんです
それどういう定義かというと
生きてるという言葉に当てはまるすべての行動は心の行動なんです
で 簡単なことなんですね
私たちは生きてるんだと簡単に言いますよ
その簡単に申し上げる場合は
何が生きてるんですか？とも
なんで生きてるんですか？と言いますかといえば
ご飯を食べる 呼吸をする
歩く 喋る ものを見る 聞く
それから考える それからいろいろ感情があります
ある それだけではなくて
我々夢も見る 寝る 寝ている時でも生きている
その働きを全てまとめて心の働きと言うんですね
そうすると心がわからないとはもう言うことはできないんですね
なぜならば 自分が見ることはわかりませんかと言えば
もうちゃんと自分で堂々と見ているし
堂々と聞いているし ものすごく堂々と考えているし
で 悲しみやら楽しみやら
いろんな幸福やら不幸やら
いろんな感情ですか このフィーリングスというものはいっぱい我々は感じているし
それだけじゃなくて いろんな物事を頭の中で考えたりするし
その働き が 心の働き そう言うと
心っていうのはもうつかみにくいものというよりは
ちゃんと我々は知っているものなんですね
つかもうとするとつかめないかもしれません
手で握ることはできないんですね
手で握られるのは体だけなんです
でも手では握れないかもしれませんだけど
ちゃんと知ってる行動は心なんですね
そこで心がいて心が行動するということは仏教で言わないんです
そこら辺なんかちょっとまあ余計に面倒くさいことを言ってるんではないかなと思うかもしれませんだけど
これは心という実体はないんです
仏教では この体バラしちゃって
全部細胞の中からでもね
細胞の核の中でも片っ端から探しても
あ これは心だとというものは見つからないんです
我々はこの仏教の特別特色っていうのはそこら辺だいたいこの
なかなか一般的には理解しないんだけど
この実体はないと言いながら
この働きだけ認めるんですね
何か働きがある 何か機能があると
その働き は心とただ名付けている
ですから心という言葉を使っているのは仏教ではありません
ごく普通の人間が まあ普通の言葉でまあ心ということを言うんです
そこでまあ仏教ではまあ何かの働きがなければ人間は心だと言わない
それはどういう働きかと探してみると
まあ数え切れないほどのいろんな働きが見つかるんですね
その働き すべてまとめて心という
じゃあわかりやすい例を申し上げます
で 世の中にこのバナナありますね
リンゴもあります ブドウもあります
桃もあります そういうものは
まあそういうまたいろいろありますね
その同じ種類のものは
そういうものはまとめて我々何を言いますか
果物という 言うんですね
バナナもリンゴも桃もブドウも
で また他のいろいろたくさんの種類がございますけど
まとめて果物と言うんです
じゃあ果物の実体は何ですか
果物というものは 正真正銘の果物の元祖たるもの
いわゆる本来のものを持ってこいと言っちゃったら
それおかしい話でしょ
本来果物という そういうものがありましたと
それからいろんな果物ができたんですかということは言わないんですね
ですから 果物は存在しないんですね
でもバナナはあります
リンゴもあります ブドウもあります
そういう全部果物なんです
そういうふうに我々は見ている
聞いている 考えている
食べている 味わっている
歩いている 座っている
そういうのは全部生きているんだからやっているもので
生きてないば瞬間で死んだ瞬間で
それ全部ストップする
その働きに心という そこでみんな私にも何回も千回も質問したことがあるんです
はっきりと心って何ですか？説明してくださいと
で 頭の中で心はこれやと掴めたがっているんです
でも本物の果物はこれだということはありえないんです
いろんなものについて我々は果物と言うんです
それだけのこと ですから働きがありまして
いわゆる喋る 見るというfunction
英語で言うと function と言えるんですね function
というのは働き 機能 見る働き
聞く働き 考える働き そういうものに心という
ですから すぐこの果物の場合はそんなには誤解しませんし
心の場合はすぐ誤解してしまっちゃう
何か心という何かあるんじゃないかなと
仏教は科学的と私は最初から申しましたから
そういう あの ちゃんとこの経験から物事をちゃんと見て
働きだけはあるんですよと
で そういうことはおっしゃってるんです
そこら辺に入っちゃうと
また話がすごく長くなりますから
できるだけ省いて喋りますけど
あの この働きというfunctionという概念は
もう少々この知識的な物事を考えになる方々はもうちょっと考えた方がいいんです
で 科学の世界から考えても
このものは本当にありますかと
聞きたくなるんですね
で エネルギーというものはあるんですね
そのエネルギーは色々な形をとって働きをする
それで私たちはものと言うだけ
言うだけなんですね そのものはその働きをしてくれなきゃ
そのものの存在もなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの前も同じ例を言いましたけど
包丁というのは切れる働きをするもので
で まあ切ることは何もできない
何かに刺したらもうぐるっと曲がっちゃうならば
私はそのものに違うことを言うんですね
人は包丁と持っていたものを
持ってきたものはもう簡単に折れるんだと
それで白いんだと ボールペンなんか持ってあるならば
その上で書けるんだと
言うならば 我々はそれに紙と言うんですね
包丁と言わない なぜかというと
包丁という言葉を使うと
ものを切れるという働きは考えているんですね
ですから この働きということは大事であって
働きに我々はものがあると思うだけのことなんです
ですから この  Thing と T H I N G
ドイツ語で Ding という言葉ありますね
何か あの何かものということで
something そういうものはないんですね
であの 僕は小さい時 すごく不思議に思った
もうすごい昔話なんですけど
思ったことがありまして
このレコードがあるんですね
で すごい昔 初めてレコードを見て
黒い円盤を見て そのそれ回しちゃうと音楽が流れるんですね
それ子供の時聞いて驚いちゃって
歌っていうのは人は口で歌うものではないかと
これ大変不思議だと で
まあまあ大体まあ年ぐらいの前の話ですからね
で あの ものすごく不思議に思ったんです
で それでこれ確かめてやらなくちゃ
探してやらなくちゃと
で 当時で やっぱりそういう機械っていうのは結構高いもので
子供には触らせないんですね
もう大人がすごい大事に使って
私たちにもまあ聞かせてはもらいますけど
もう触らせてはもらえません
ですから どうしようかと考えて考えて
このいつかもううちの人々はどうか行っちゃったところで
これは 見てみると思って
まあ親とかどうかどうか出かけちゃったら
さっさと弟と一緒にもう全部片っ端から出して
で いろいろ見るんですね
音は僕は探すとか 蓄音なんとかという
この昔風のこのグラモフォンというものなんです
電気的なものじゃないんです
ですから もう簡単に見られますから
そこで一つ一つ部分を中だこうだとかして見たんです
見ても全然見つからないんですね
これどうやって音が出る？このからくりは何でしょうかと
で 音が出るものももう抜け抜いちゃって
それに二人で口を当てて喋ったりするとでっかい音がする
これで音がでっかくなるんだとか
そういうのはわかるんだけど
ですから思ったのは この黒い円盤に何かある秘密があるんだと
で 円盤を見てもなんかこのグルーヴですと英語で言うんですけど
このグルーヴだけあるんであって
全然そこでもしかするとこのラベルではないかと思ってラベルを外そうとしたんですね
これなかなか頑固で外せないんですね
ものすごくぴったりして
で これもう削って外っちゃった
外っちゃったならばもうバレちゃうんですね
親に殴られちゃうし ですからとにかく丁寧に外して
中身のこの秘密を見て探って
それからまたわからないように貼ってやろうと思ったんだけど
それできなかったんです
そこでもう頭の中でこれやっぱり何とかして壊してみたいという気持ちがあるんです
壊してでも中を見たいんだと
でもそんなことをやっちゃったら
やっぱりもうひどい目に遭いますから
で もう待ってるんで とにかく希望して夢でも見るんです
とにかくあれ壊してみたいと
で まあ後であまり時間経ってないうちに 2 3週間かな
で このやっぱり壊れたレコード見つかったんです
いわゆる使えないもの
あって これどう喜びで片っ端から壊しちゃったんです
大人から見れば 何のことをこのガキがやってると思うかもしれません
でもガキにとってはこれ大変なことなんです
で バラしてバラして このとにかく僕をわさわさと見たのを
このラベルを貼ってるところの中身な中なんですね
何かあるんだと でも何もなかったんです
でも大変失望でわからなくて
で  あまり人と喋るぐらいは
その当時では別に言葉そんな上手ではなかったし
その人々に説明してくれることまでは知らなかったかもしれません
その法則は で そこに何も実体はないんですね
何も実体がない これは音楽を作るとこ
味噌はこれですということはないんですね
で グルーヴというものは
まあ昔はいろいろギザギザ入ってたんだけど
今はそれなりの電気信号で同じことをしていて
それも音でも音楽でもなんでもない
で いろんなものを組み合わせたところで
我々の耳に音というものは生まれてくるんですね
じゃあ音というものはまたあるかというと
そうでもなくて ただ空気の振動だけなんですね
いろいろ工夫して空気を振動させる
じゃあその空気の振動も耳に入ります
けど 耳に入るわけじゃないんです
空気が耳に触れていつでも触れてますから
耳はまあまたちょっとした似ているような振動するだろうと思いますけど
似ているか似てないかわからないんです
それで我々は何か頭の中で感じて
それに音というんです
音という実体を探そうとすると
それが見つからなくなっちゃうんです
でも何か働いてくれなきゃ我々はあるとは言わない
そのようにもう考えてほしいんです
このいろいろ働きがあるんだと
その働きだけあって 実体というものはないと
そこまで言う必要はございませんが
で ここでこういうことを言ったのは
我々の体の中で心という
このコンピューターの CPU みたいに
このプロセッシングユニットみたいなものがないということを言うためなんです
コンピューターの場合は CPU という IC がちょんのほの小さなものがありまして
それはもう全部もうもう偉いものなんですね
すべての仕事はそちらでやっているんですから
そういうものはないんです
じゃあコンピューターの CPU というのはそんなに偉いものかというと
他の部品揃っていないと何の意味もない
ただのガラクタなんです
ただのガラクタ 何の役にも立たない
子供のおもちゃにもならないんです
ですから コンピューターの場合も
CPU こそコンピューターの魂やとはそんなにいい加減には言えませんしね
人間にとっては一番大事なのは
その CPU なんとかそんなものじゃなくて
あのモニターなんですね
モニターで見て じっと見て
いろいろなことをやってますから
でもコンピューターから見れば
モニターっていうのはただのアウトプット装置で
何のこともないんです
自分の結果は電気信号で外へ出すだけのことで
ですから このそういうもので
このこれこそ偉いということはない
CPU は自分の何とか働きをする
他の IC が自分の何とか働きをする
だから必要ということだけであって
その働きをしなかったら我々はゴミと言うんです
CPU を何とかのことでいかれちゃったら
もう全部もう使えないんだと
ゴミだと 捨てちゃうんです
で そういう風に この体の中に何かこの実体のような心という何かあると思わない方が仏教的なんですね
皆様はそう思いたいと
そう思っていたいと思うならば
それは自由ですが 仏教ではそういう何かあるとは言わない
ですから すべてまとめたところで
何か働きが生まれてくる
それが心ですと 生きていること
そこで生きていることは心というなれば
生きていることを勉強すればどうですかと
それでお釈迦様は生きているということについていろいろなことをお話をしているんですね
皆様よく聞いている一言言葉がありまして
このドゥッカですよと苦しみですよという言葉があるんですね
それはお釈迦様の言葉でドゥッカと言うんですね
仏教では 日本では空 苦しみという漢字を当てているんです
で まあ存在は苦ですよと
ドゥッカですよと で 苦といえばちょっと意味が狭いんだから
だいたいあまり私たちは使わないようにしているんです
意味が分からなくても
このパーリ語のドゥッカということを使いましょうと
なぜならば 苦といえば苦しいという
この意味がものすごく確定して固定して狭いんですね
なんか痛いという意味ですから
で 仏教で言ってるドッカはもっと意味が広いんですね
いわゆるこの意味が 日本語で言えばいくつかあります
一つは 不満 それから不安
いわゆる安定していない状態
次にこの味として 感覚としては結局はこの苦しいと
苦しみの意味ですから
不安 不満 苦しみという三つの
あ もう一つあります さすがに
虚しい 実体ないということ
虚しい という意味で使ってるんです
で じゃあ虚しいという最後に私は忘れようとした言葉からちょっと考えてみましょう
虚しいというのは じゃあ我々は一生懸命生きてるんですね
じゃあ目的は何ですかと
何を目指して生きていらっしゃいますかと
何のために生きてるんですかと
生きることのゴールは何でしょうかと
これやったらもうあなたは人生のゴールに達しましたよと言えるものが何かございますかと聞いてみてください
自分に ありますか？何か
生きる目的というものは
ないんですね ですから
まあドッカですよと ただ生きているだけなんです
我々は 赤ちゃんがただお腹すいたらミルクを飲んだり
もう泣いたり笑ったり
ただそれやってるだけで子供は遊んだり
いろんなことをやったりしていて
それの時その時のなんとかしているんだけど
これは目的やとは誰も思ってないんです
そこで歳を重ねて もう体の機能はもうあまり動かなくなっちゃって
結局終わってしまっちゃうんですね
一般の人々はごまかしをするんですね
嘘を言ってるんですね
例えば大事な役目がありまして
あなたは生まれてきたんだと
ああいうのは嘘なんです
なぜならば 本当にそうであるならば
なんで本人が知らないんですかね
例えば私はどんな役目があって生まれてきたか全然わかりませんし
たまたまこういう仕事をしているだけのことなんです
で そういうのはまあもう人間ただ無責任で
その時の問題を抑えるために言うことなんでね
例えば子供はすごいいい加減に遊びばっかしで
親の言うことも聞かないで
まあ好き勝手にいろんな行動をやり始めたら
親はそんなことしてはいけませんと
あなた方はもう大事な目的があって生まれてきたんだとか
ああだこうだ言って 子供たちのこの行動をなんとか抑えてもらおうとしているんです
例えば 子供たちは中学生ぐらいになってくると
やっぱり人生は虚しいということには極力気づくんです
この騙されていたんですかということを大人に
それから大人にも社会に適応するんですから
この中学生ぐらい 小学生ぐらいというのは大変誰でも精神的なショックを受ける時期なんです
自分でものを見て考えたりすると始めるんだから
そこで人生嫌になったりとか
自殺図ろうとかしてくると
みんなもうせっかく尊い命ですからとか
もう大事な命ですから
もう大変何か大事な目的があって
役目があって あなた方は生まれたのではないかとかいうことを言うんです
でもあまり納得はしないよ
本人が そんなことあるならば
それ知るはずなんですね
知らない ですから その時の問題をなんとかなんとか抑えておこうということで
我々は無責任で研究もしないで
研究もしないで 試みもしないで
無責任でまったくの理論もなしに喋るんです
それで不思議なことは
それは人生論になっちゃうんですね
人間の生きる目的はとか
人生はとか もうすごい分厚いテキストとかいっぱいあるんです
あれは全部全くの英語でいう言葉に blabla という言葉がありまして
もうただの blabla なんです
いわゆるまあ無責任な話なんです
本当にあなたはそれを試してみたんですかと
と言えば 全然そうじゃないんです
それで仏教はすごい確実に具体的に物事を見ているんだから
きちんと具体的に科学者の目で実際に生きているものを見ていると
発見できるのは 人は生まれて大きくなって
年取って病気になって消えてしまう
動物を見ても 小さい時生まれて
それなりの遊んだりして
必死で生きてきて 年取って死んでしまうか
誰かに食べられるかで終わっちゃうと
消えちゃうと だから結局言えるのは
我々は何のために生きているんですかと
死ぬために生きているんですかということなんです
動物を見ているとすごく悲しくなるんで
たまに 命かけて子供 子育てするでしょ
そこで終わったら親が死ぬ
それで子供は次に命かけて自分の次の子供を作る
それで親が死ぬと その循環だけなんですね
我々はちょっと寿命は長いんだから
ちょっと怠けてるだけで
人生に 我々の人生もこのもう 80年の人生を 10年に縮んで考えれば
それしか残らないんです
人間の寿命は 7年ぐらいにしてしまえば
もう 1年  2年でも大人でしょうに
それで何か食べ物を探したりして
また結婚あるかないかわかりませんだけど
また相手を見つかって子孫を作って
それ 2年ぐらいでもうまた大人にしちゃって
自分がもうそれで年だからもう死ぬと
それで終わっちゃうんですね
ですから この鮭みたいな人生なんですね
必死で川を上る 上ってどうなるんですか？と死ぬ
だから川を上る時はものすごい大事な目的があるのように
必死で石があろうがもうダムがあろうがもう関係なく
もういくら怪我したっても 40回でも飛んでみるんですね
この何か邪魔なものがあったら
それで壁とかにぶつかって
ぶつかって ぶつかって
怪我して それで力尽きて
それで途中で死ぬし 飛べたものはまた上を行って
それでもう卵を産む 卵を産んだところで疲れて死ぬと
そういうふうに客観的に見ると
ちゃんと正しく我々に掴まれる事実から見ると
死ぬために生きているんですね
それで馬鹿馬鹿しいというのは
死ぬということはいつも簡単なんですね
いつでも死ねる どんなものでも死ねる
ご飯食べてでも死ねる
ご飯食べないで でも死ねるんでね
例えば食べて食べて食べて死ぬこともできるし
全く食べないで死ぬこともできるし
で 病気を治すために飲む薬あるでしょ
薬飲んで簡単に死ねるんです
我々ちょっと頭が痛くなったりすると
アスピリンとかなんとかお飲みになりますね
それじゃあアスピリンでも飲んでみてください
死んじゃうんです すごい簡単に
ですから この世の中で私は冗談で言いますけど
無料 あの無料のものはたった一つしかないんだと
それは死ぬことだけなんです
それはだけタダなんです
他のすべてのものには何か払わなくちゃいけないんです
なんかということは 他のものをやるならば
それはあんた余計なことをやってるんだから
ちゃんとお金払いなさいと
あなたは死ぬために生まれたんだから
死ぬことだけは無料ですよ
というような話なんですね
ご飯食べるんだったら
じゃあそれなりのお仕事をしなさいと
いわゆる払いなさいと
結婚したければ だったらそれなりの苦労しなさいと
払いなさいと 全部払わなくちゃいけないんですね
死ぬっていうことはだけ無料
そこで皆様 ちょっとおかしいではないかと思うかもしれません
じゃあ病院なんかにね
行ってね まあ年取ったらすごいお金かかるんではないかと
あれは死ぬためにかかるお金じゃなくて
死なない死なないで頑張ろうと思ってるんだから
バカバカらしいことをやってるんだからお金がかかるんです
延命措置入れたりとか
もう人工呼吸なんかしたりとかで
点滴で栄養入れたりするんだから
あんなバカなことやってるんだからお金がかかるんであって
死ぬことだけはもういつでも無料なんです
ということは 我々にまあそれしかついてないんですね
ということは よく考えると
生きるということは まあバカバカらしくて虚しいではないかと
それでお釈迦様はすべてはドッカですよという言葉で説明するんですね
そういうのこの不可思議な理解しにくい尊い真理というよりは
目の前にあるきちんとした事実なんです
そこでもう一つ 私は言葉を申し上げました
この不満ですよと じゃあ人生っていうのはどういうものかというと
客観的に見てください
自分の人生 不満だらけなんです
何をしても やっぱり完全満足は得られないんですね
じゃあご飯食べる そこで完全に満足した経験がありますかというと
ない 小さい時は遊びました
完全に遊んで満足したんですか？というとそうじゃない
親には必ずしも怒られたんですね
もういい加減やめなさいと
もっと遊びたいのに で
完全満足したことはないんです
健康な方々はもう大勢いらっしゃいますけど
自分の健康状態に完全満足だと自信満々だと
言えませんね じゃあ ご結婚なさってる方々の方がこちらでも多いんですけど
自分の相手は完璧だと
これという問題はもうないと
言えますかね 全然そんなことはないんです
で 自分の体のこと 誰でも自分の体のことはものすごく愛情があって
執着がありますけど 自分の体は完璧だ
完全に綺麗だ 美しいんだと思えないんですね
じゃあ喋るでしょ 人々と
私は完璧に喋りましたと
あの人にこれはもう完璧に説明してあげましたと言えることはありますか？ないんです
子供にしつけをするでしょうに
自分の子供だから言うことはきちんともう合理的に納得いけるように
聞いただけで心はもう良くなって治せるように
きちんと完璧に喋った覚えがありますか？そうはないんですね
ですから どう何をしても
何を考えても 我々は感じているのは
まあまだまだと もっとしっかりやらなくちゃと
ですから どんな人に聞いても
誰で口にある言葉はもうまだまだですよと
で こういうことあるでしょ？例えば日本というのは長寿社会でございますし
そこで歳 歳なっちゃうと
昔風に言えばもうもうやめた方がいいんですけど
人生っていうのは でももう長寿社会だから何言いますか
あ 人生はこれからだと
もう歳になってこれからやっていうのは
今まで生きてきてないということなんですね
いわゆる今まで生きてきたことにはやっぱり不満があるということなんですね
これからやというと これからだとこれからどんどん悪くなる一方ですから
それでまた不満になってしまっちゃうんですね
せっかく六十歳になって退社して
じゃあ人生はこれからだ
これから頑張るんだと言ったってもう高血圧
糖尿病 腰が痛いと膝が曲げれないとか
がんになったとか もう出てくるわ出てくるわ
それの処理することで人生終わってしまっちゃうんですね
それで不満だらけで死んでしまっちゃうんです
それだったらごまかしを言わないで
嘘を言わないで きちんと科学的に人生を見て評価して
どんな言葉で言えますかと言えば
不安そのものなんですね
不満そのものなんですね
それにパーリ語ではドゥッカと言うんです
次に僕はこの不安という言葉
ちょっとほんのかすかに説明いたしたいんだけど
不安というのは安定していない
いつでもこの状態は変化していくんですね
それをよく感じていらっしゃるでしょ
若い人々はなんであんなに若いのに落ち着いてないんですかね
大人から見れば羨ましいでしょうに
やっぱりその若さっていうのはすごい短いんだと知ってるんです
で どんなものも安定してないんですね
すぐもう変えてしまっちゃう
変化してしまっちゃうんです
悪いものは変化するのはありがたい
例えば病気になって体が痛くてしょうがない時は
それは不安定だから消えちゃう
その時はありがたいんだけど
やっぱり我々の楽しみも消えていっちゃうんですね
幸福も消えていっちゃうんですね
せっかく仕事をして得た収入ももう消えていっちゃうんですね
不安定不安定不安定 安定しない
停止しない 静止しない
それはちょっとしたもっと幅広い事実なんです
いわゆるすべてのものは存在
物質もすべて変化しつつ
変える変える変える 変化
変化 変化 どこまで変化するかともう終わりがないんです
だからかって地球はなかったんだけど
普通のエネルギーの塊だけでした
そのエネルギーはまた変化
変化 変化して 地球になったり
また変化して こういう空気やらいろんなものをできてきて
また変化して 温度が下がってきて
また変化して それなりの酸素やらいろいろもの生まれてきて
また変化して  DNA の小さなものができたりしてたり
それまた生命が生まれたり
また変化してまた変化してと
どこまで変化していくんですかね
これは終わりがないんです
そこでまあ最終的にはエネルギーはもう一応太陽もエネルギーは出して出して出して終わっちゃいますからね
同時に地球も消えてしまっちゃうし
我々も消えてしまう そこで終わったんです
終わらないんです もう変化
変化して続けちゃうんですね
ですから この不安定状態
変化する状態にも 仏教でドゥッカという言葉でまとめて言うんですね
そのドゥッカと一言葉っていうのは
ですから 大変膨大な事実をまとめておっしゃっていることで
たった一言葉で人生はそんなもんだよと言ってるんだから
大変便利な言葉なんです
キーワードなんです そういう仏教というのは
この目覚めるためのキーワード
そういうキーワードにあまりケチをつけてはいけないんです
そんなお釈迦さん 人生は苦といったっても
やっぱり人生は楽しいではないかと
そういうのは観察はしてない
何も物事を見てない 人生楽しいということ
人々に聞きたいことがあるんですね
あんた全然心配したことなんかなかったんですかと
病気になったことはなかったんですかと
死ぬ恐れは全くなかったんですとかね
仕事で苦労したことは全くなかったんですかと
人と喧嘩したことは全くなかったんですかと
こんちくしょうと思ったことは全くなかったんですかと
そういう人に限って そういう気持ちがすごい強烈なんです
すごい怒りでもう堂々となんとかして生きてよ
本当に人生の苦しみは少なく
楽しみが多く味わっている人々というのは別にもう落ち着いているんです
ですから このあまりケチをつけてはいけないと思いますけど
そういうのはキーワード
確かめるとどんどん研究していくと
そういう結論に来る そこでわざわざお釈迦様はこういう大胆な言葉を使うのは
人間というのはみんな嘘つきだからなんです
大事な命ですよと というと
なんで我々言うことは
子供たちはすぐ反発するでしょう
子供たちはしっかりしているんです
大事な命ですと言われたら
子供たち何言ってるんですかね
この親父はと 思っちゃうんです
無意識的に 全然さっぱりわからないことを言ってるんだから
それよりはこんなことをやっちゃったら
お父さんがすごい悲しいですよと言った方がわかりやすいんです
そうは言わない 大事な命ですよと
選ばれた命ですよと 誰に選ばれたんですかね
この審査会はどこにいたんですかね
全然わからない ですから
そういう言葉で我々の苦しみを
人生の虚しさを転換にするんです
英語でこれをワイプウォッシュと言うんです
白 色で塗っちゃえばもう汚れが見えませんだから
哲学はだいたいそんなもんなんですね
で 例えば人間の そういう心の働きになります
働きのことになりますけど
皆様方には本当に光り輝く尊い命がついてるんだと
ジャイナ教という古いお釈迦様の宗教よりは少々古い宗教がインドでありまして
その宗教でそういう こう言うんですね
すべての生命には魂 アートマンというものがあるんだと
そのアートマンはこの洗脳
すべての洗脳というんですかね
いわゆる万能で すべての能力がついていて
全知ですよと すべてを知っているんだと
そこでこの瞬時にすべてを
一切をいつでも知っていると
そのアートマンは我々には確実にあるんだと言っているんです
そういう話を言うと なんだかちょっと気持ちいいんじゃないですか
ああそうですかと ああいうのはごまかしなんです
なんで気持ちよくなるんですかね
人は死んでも魂は死にませんと言ったら気持ちいいでしょ
霊魂は不滅で永遠ですよと
科学者はバカバカらしくて
もう真実は本当にわかってないんだと
というと なんとなく気持ちいいんですね
それで現代人はよくこの精神世界を走っているんですね
探し求めているんですね
この超越した智慧の世界
それは置いておいて 気持ちいいことは確かなんですね
あれなんですかと そこをまた仏教は心理学的に物事を見るんですね
我々はすごい病気で悩んでいると
もう例えばこのまあまあ女性の方だったらすごい痩せたいんですね
そこで痩せるためにはもう魔法のような魔法のような薬があるんだと
これはほんのちょっとだけ舐めただけで
ひと月まあ 5キロぐらいは痩せますよと言おうとも飛んでいって
そんなものは買ってしまっちゃうんですね
で あれなんですかと 例えば病気な人にもうこういう薬さえあればもう全部治りますよと言っちゃったら
もう使っちゃうんですね
そういうことなんです
すごい素晴らしいお医者さんがいるんだ
そのお医者さんがその病気に対してはもう世界一だと言われると
なんとかその人に接見したくなる
そこで一番嫌なことは
薬は治療はないということなんです
一番嫌なんです それは聞きたくない
あ これはあなたはなんとか何とか病気ですね
それで先生何とかしてくれと
薬はありませんから まあそれであなた死ぬでしょう
言われたら あの医者さんのところにもう二度とは行かない
みんなに言いふらしちゃって
あの先生のところに行くなと
それぐらいやっちゃうんです
ということは こういう心理なんです
それは心の どういうことかというと
やっぱり我々は毎日死を味わっている
不安を味わっている 不満を味わっている
今の幸福はいつ消えるかわからないんです
いつでも心の中でビクビクしているんです
そこで死んでも もう霊魂は永遠に不滅ですよと言ったらありがたがるんです
その中にもある真実は
人生はドゥッカですよということなんです
ですから 世の中では この私たちはいくらか落ち着いてくれるために
我々を抑えてもらう 抑えておくために
哲学と宗教と科学と それで政治と経済というものがあるんです
で 抑えてくれるんです
ちょっと ちょっと落ち着いてくれるんです
きちんとした政府がありますと
きちんとした政治システムと法律体系があると言っちゃったら落ち着くんです
経済システムはもうしっかりしているんだと落ち着くんです
すごい大きな会社に入っちゃったら落ち着くんです
この会社は潰れることはないんだと
それだけのことなんです
別にそんなものあるわけじゃない
潰れない会社あるわけでもないし
しっかりしている政府もあるわけじゃない
しっかりした経済システムも世の中ではない
私たちはそう思いたいだけ
で 科学の世界も同じく
作るものは一つもそんなに役に立つものではないし
じゃあで そういう風にサカソンはこの人生の本当の姿を我々に教えているんです
なんでそれを教えるんですかというと
それは心なんですから
心 心っていうのは生きていることだから
別に心という実体あるわけじゃなくて
こんな複雑な構造が心なんです
喋ったり考えたりするということ
だから 仏教と他の宗教の教えっていうのは
宗教だから同じ ほとんど似ているものを喋るのはごく普通に当たり前でしょうに
でも 仏教の逆さの本当の経典を読むと
もともとの経典 大乗経典ではなくて
全然衝撃を起こさないがないんです
なんか脅す 脅しちゃうんですね
人間 なんかすごく心にものすごく響くんで
あれ これで自分がダメだというふうに感じさせちゃうんですね
それで あ これはわからないんだと
ということも何一つもないんです
なんか理論ぜーぜーにしてよくわかるんです
またか言って なるほどと
大乗経典読むと違うんですね
偉い仏様たちがいて そこでまたすごい菩薩たちが現れ
それで大宇宙にあるありとあらゆるものどもが現れてきて
お化けやら野菜やらガキやら何だかんでも
そこでものすごいもうすごい超能力神通力が出てきて
もうブッダのもうこの額のところから何か光が出て
それからその中からすべてのあの 1万何々とか何とかという大宇宙が見えたりとか
まあくだらない お腹が痛くなるほど嘘ばっかり語ったしからない
それは宗教なんです ああ
ありがたい ありがたいと思っちゃうんですね
それは生きることは全然ありがたくないんだからなんです
そういう味は全くないんです
なんかお釈迦様の教えというのは
いい加減にしろというふうな感じなんです
そんな感じの話なんです
何やってるんですか？と
ある日 このなんかお坊さんが瞑想中居眠りしていたんですね
まあごく普通なことで
まああまり瞑想うまくいかないと
まあ眠ってしまっちゃうっていうのは
まあごく普通なことで居眠りしていると
お釈迦様は叱ったという
この叱りの言葉の恐ろしさ
すごい恐ろしい言葉を叱るんですね
あなた方は全てもう燃え尽きてもう死にかけているのに
何様ですかと 寝ているのと
すっごいキツい言葉で
もう いわゆるこの体中全部火つけてもう燃えているんだと
それでよく寝るんですねと
というふうな言葉で これ今すぐもうこの頭の言葉
ちょっと忘れちゃっても思い出せます
一言葉思い出せば 全部原文思い出しますけど
で 脅かしちゃうんですね
普通だったらまあ起きなさいと
寝るなというぐらいでいいんだけど
そうないんです まあ脅して
それはそれ キツく言うんです
まあとにかくそういうふうに
この我々にわかりやすく事実だけ喋る
別にわかりやすく言ってるわけじゃないんです
事実だからわかりやすい
それだけのこと 冬は寒いですよと私は説明する必要ありますか？全然ありませんよ
温度は云々とか そんなこと言ったっても
全然もうどうでもいいことで冬は寒い
ただそれだけ 事実だから
まあよくわかります  そういうふうにお釈迦様はまあ生きることを説明しているんです
人を躍らせようとか 機嫌取ろうとかね
人の機嫌を取って なんとかいい美しい言葉を語ってあげて
まあ抑えてあげましょうと
では全くない その逆を言うんですね
美しい 大変この洗練して
この言葉を選んで人を感動する美しい言葉は 1000 ぐらい喋ったっても
ただの無駄話ですと たった一言でも心に響く言葉あるならば
それだけいいんですと
というふうに言うんです
そういうふうな この仏教の特色でもあります
その話は置いておいて
じゃあ心の特色という
今日のテーマに移ります
別にテーマずっと繋がってはありますけどね
いくらか分かりやすくしようと
いろいろあっちこっち飛び出して喋ってるんです
じゃあ我々の生きることは心ですから
生きるということの特色って言えば何でしょうかね
国境の特色というのは何かありますか
見る事の特色とか何かあります
そんな言えるものはないんです
でも やっぱりいくらかはあるんです
じゃあどこから始まりましょうか
いっぱいありますけど
で まあわかりやすいところから言えば
このまず自分という実感があります
みんなにあるんです 自分
私という実感 あれすごいおかしいんだけど
それで全部まとめちゃうんですね
自分という言葉で あれ
ただの言葉だけじゃなくて
なんとなく自分という感じてる実感があるんですね
本当はあれすごいおかしいんです
どちらが自分ですか？この体の
どちらが自分ですか？手
耳 鼻 脳細胞 心臓 どちらもないんです
手の場合は私の手と言うんです
心臓の場合 私の心臓と言うんです
脳みその場合 私の脳細胞と言うんです
じゃあ肝心な私というものはどこにいるんですかね
どこにもいない たとえ脳の腫瘍と何とかという言葉
発音が間違ってるかもしれません
脳の中にいる出来物出ちゃうんですね
たまに 脳腫瘍と言うんですか
そういうものができたというならば
いろいろ自分の考え方
生き方 いろいろおかしくなっちゃうんで
そこでお医者さんがあんたの頭の中でちょっともう脳腫瘍であって
それは摘出しなくちゃ
いわゆる取れなくちゃいけないんだと言ったら平気で言うでしょ
はい お願いしますと それを取りまして
私の命を助けてくださいと
だから私を助けてくれるならば
脳細胞も取って取ってもいいやということでしょうに
だからおかしくて おかしくて
もう本当におかしくて
もう笑えるものなんです
普通 皆様はそういうことに笑いませんが
僕らはそういうものによく笑っちゃうんです
あれ 何が私ですかと 誰を守らせてるんですかね
脳細胞捨てちゃって そこで自分の胃なんかはね
腸胃とかこのあのダイジェストシステムというものを
消化機能っていうのは我々すごい大事にしてるんですね
こういうものを食べたらもう胃にはいいんだと
こういうものを食べたら胃に胃に悪いんだから食べてはいけませんと
いろいろ気をつけて気をつけて守ってるんです
そこでちょっとまあ 消化の過程がちょっとおかしいとかなんとかと調べたところで
胃と小腸にはもうかなり広げているんだと
ガンはと言われる そうすると我々はなんと言いますかね
先生お願いしますかったら
まあいいですよ 手術してください
それで先生は何のことなく
胃も腸もできるだけもう 3 分の 2 ぐらいもう
切って捨てちゃう あれ
誰を守ってるんですかと
結局何でも我々は自分を守るために捨てられるものということは
自分でないということなんです
今は手は元気だから お医者さんがあなたの手はすごい元気で
これカットしましょうかと言っちゃったら
もうやらせてあげませんね
毎日この病気の手ばっかり私は切断したりするんだけど
やっぱり一度たまにしっかりした綺麗な手一つちゃんとノコギリでカット切断したいんだと言っちゃったら
我々は絶対それだけはもうごめんと言うでしょうね
それで私と言うんだけど
もし自分の手が死んでしまっちゃって
それ体に付いていたら大変危ないんだと言われたところで
何のことなく切断して捨てちゃう
手も捨てちゃう それでも生きていると
そういう風に何かこの
人間ってなんかすごいおかしいんですね
自分自分と言いながら
この辺は自分だと そこでいるところは何か危なくなって
いや そっちじゃなくてこっち私ですよ
そっちじゃなくてこっち私ですと
あっちこっち飛んでるような感じで
結局どこも自分じゃなくなっちゃうんですね
で そういうことで自分という実感
それを完全な妄想概念なんです
それをこの見ることから
聞くことから 味わうことから
体で感じることから それから頭で考えることから生まれるものなんです
それはつなげるために
ただ人使っている概念だけ
でもただの概念なんですけど
心はそれに執着している
このすべての働き 生きる働きは
初めの講演会でこの反論してくださいと言われた
申し上げましたけど 皆様反論がしたいところいっぱいあるかもしれませんだけど
遠慮してらっしゃるかもしれませんし
だから何ですかと聞きたくなるならないんですかね
別に実感があって 別に何が何が悪いんですか
そういうこと問題なんで
それで私たちはこの全然存在しない
実体のない ありえない自分を守ろうとしているんです
そこら辺問題なんです
自分を守るためにご飯食べて
勉強して 運動してと いろんなことをして
その自分はどこにいるかというと
わかりませんと わからないものはどうやって守られますかね
わからない自分 そこでせっかく楽しみ
楽しみ 楽しんで 気楽に
スムーズに 空気のように生きていられるのに
我々はありとあらゆるこの
このドッカというよりは本当に苦しみが増えちゃうんです
この私という実感から
限りないドッカ作るんです
どういうことかというと
こういうことなんですね
私がいるんだから 私を守らなくちゃいけない
それで私を守るためには
もう遊んでばっかりはダメなんですと
勉強もしなくちゃと 仕事を探さなくちゃと
仕事をするだけではダメですと
きちんと堂々とライバルを作って競争していかなくちゃと
いろんな世界が生まれてくる
そこで何やっても失敗する
失敗するとものすごく悔しい
悔しい思いで生きてなくちゃいけない
で どんどん年取る 年取ればそれでそれでいいのに
やっぱり自分を守らなくちゃいけない
それで戦うんです 年取らないようにと
美しさは消えていく 放っておけばいいのに
やっぱりそんな消えちゃったら自分はダメになるんだと
守ろうとする 戦う人と自分を別だと思う
敵を作る ライバルを作る
そこでライバルがいるんだから
他人がいるんだから そこに妬みやら嫉妬やら恨みやら怒りやら
ありとあらゆるものが生まれてくる
息子さんのためにせっかくお嫁さんもらっちゃいますけど
母親は私というえらい実感があるんだから
そこで新しい女の子が家に入ってきて
もう大変楽しいなのに
もうすごい限りない苦しみを味わっちゃうんですね
お嫁さんに対していろんなことを言ったり
ああだこうだとか お互いに喧嘩したりと
なんであんなバカなことをするんですかと
でもやってしまっちゃうんです
お嫁さんの味噌汁は味が良くないんだと
それはもうお母さんがずっと食べてきた味が自分には体に慣れてるならば
あなたのお味噌汁は食べられませんから
あなたの旦那さんに作ってあげなさいと
私は自分のもの別に作りますよと
二人で別々に作ればいいし
そうはいかないんですね
やっぱり戦って抑えて
自分が力強いよと言いたがっちゃうんです
その自分という実感があるんだからなんです
ちょっとしたことで人間は喧嘩する
そこにこのお釈迦様が言ったドッカ以外
想像以上の 本当に我々が実感している苦しみ
生きる苦しみがそこに生まれるんです
皆様方もいろんなカウンセリングのところに行ったり
仏教を勉強したり こういう講演会に来たり
他の宗教を勉強したりするのは
それを苦しみがあるだからなんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃった苦しみがわかっているんだからじゃないんです
いろんな物事うまくいかないとトラブルばっかりで
喧嘩ばっかりで 争いばっかりで
混乱ばっかりで この争い戦い
この英語の言葉を言ったらコンフリクト
全部あのコンフリクトばっかりなんです
ですから こんなこの別に私という実感があって何が悪いんですかと
いい加減なことを言うよりは
そこは大事なポイントなんです
食べるんだから私がいるというふうに感じる
見るんだから私が見ると感じる
聞くんだから私が聞くと感じる
その心のそういう働きによって
私がいるというふうな妄想概念が生まれる
そこでその化け物がすべてを支配するようになっちゃう
それで苦しみしか作ってくれない
戦えと 私を守れと 守ってあげたいんだけど
守るものがなければ守られませんでしょうに
我々はどんな武器を持っていたっても
もうじゃあ撃てと言ったっても
ターゲットは何ですかと
ターゲットがなければ撃てないでしょうに
だから片っ端からもうあっちこっち撃ちっぱなしなんですね
でもターゲットがないんだからもう点なんですね
そういうことで 我々は自分を守ると努力はして
ありとあらゆる苦しみを味わっちゃいますけど
結局自分がいないんだから
人生はで終わっちゃうんです
何の目的もなく終わってしまっちゃうんです
そういうことで それは心の特徴
なんですね 別々な働きなのに
もう全部まとめちゃうんです
妄想概念 じゃあ大体まああまり深く取る一つの項目
一つの言葉はもう二時間
三時間の話したっても終わらないほどの内容はあまりもありすぎて
まあそこら辺でほどほどにやめますけど
で 一つの心の特色は自分という実感
それは我々のすべての苦しみを作る妄想概念である
死んじゃったら成仏したくなるのも
天国に行きたくなるのも
この自分という実感があるんだからなんです
心は自由にならないんです
穏やかにならないんです
じゃあ  これ自動的に回さないんですかね
自動的に回るんですけど
止まってますね  止まってますね
フォースかけてるんですか？ 自動のあれを切ったらみたいですね
両方行ったでしょ これ何分
ですか  また時間ありますね
回ってないです  いえ  じゃあ次の特色に行きます
で それからこのさらに我々のこの苦しみやいろんなこの悪い方を作ってくる
この心のこの悪い側面
ちょっと考えてみましょう
で この仏教の言葉でこのよくよく欲という言葉がございます
よくこの欲張りの欲 勝愛というも言うんです
で パーリ語でこのローバと読みます
パーリ語のではローバいろいろ言葉がございます
タンハーという言葉もあります
それはこの分かりやすい言葉で言えば
この自己愛みたいなものなんですね
この欲という感じで まあとりあえず今のうちはいいんですけど
ただこの一般的な欲というぐらいの意味じゃないんです
で この自己愛みたいなもので
この自分という存在というのは作ってしまって
次それをすごく愛してしまっちゃうんですね
自分という実感を 全ての生命はそんなもんなんです
自分がいる その自分が大事だから
自分がすっごい好きですと
自分が自分のことはものすごい好きなんです
だから必死で守ろうとしてるんです
心臓でも腎臓でも何でも捨てる
それを守るためには それぐらいこの自分を愛してると執着している自己愛
それも一つの心の特色なんです
それにつなげて出てくるのは
この ですから この楽しませてあげようと自分を
自分を楽しませてあげようという気持ち
それはどんな言葉でいいんでしょうかね
自己愛があって それから生まれるのは自分を楽しませるというか
もう自分が楽しむと言ったって日本語的ですけど
自分が楽しむというよりは
自分を楽しませるというふうに
ちょっとからくりややこしく言った方が
僕にとっては説明しやすいんです
分かりやすい言葉でお書きになってください
自分が楽しむと それは心が楽しみがってるんですね
まず我々は死にたくないってことがあるんです
私は死にたくない 体が死んでも私は死にたくない
それはもう人間はものすごい強烈に心の中にあるんです
このあまりこの欲のない方々は
このどんどん年になってくると
まあまあ 私はまあどうせ死ぬんだってよくわかってるんです
ですごく落ち着いてはいるんですよ
立派な方々 いくらでもたくさんいるんです
でも その方々でも別に悟ってるわけじゃないんだから
心の中にはこの体はもうどうせもうガタガタだからもう死ぬでしょうと
まあいいやと でも体が死んでも私は死なないっていうことはそこにあるんです
ですから まあ死にたくないという強烈なこの希望あるんです
それから 死なない時はどうしますかと
それで死なないうちはとにかく死なないためには頑張りますけど
もう死なないうちはもう楽しもうと
この楽しみ論で生きてるんです
で 一番基本的なそういうところで
何のために人間生きてますかというと
楽しむために ためなんですね
楽しむために生きてるんです
それをみんな自分をごまかしちゃって
自分に嘘つけたりして結構苦しんでますけど
それを理解しておけば
もう正直な心でもっと楽なんで
人生は ですから この何も知識ない時はなかった時
世の中のこと何も知らなかった時は結構楽しかったんです
小さい時とかね お母ちゃんお腹減ったと言っちゃったら
もうちゃんとご飯はある
そのご飯はどうやって作ったか
それはどんな仕事をしてお金をもう貰ったかと
そんなのどうでもいいんです
子供には あれ欲しいと言っちゃったら
それお母さんにお金あるかないか
そんな関係ないんです
それもらったら楽しいんです
で 何も知らない時はすごく楽しかったんです
そこは心の基本的な働きだけやる時なんですね
で それ私で忘れたわけじゃないんです
ですから 我々はなぜ物事を見ているんですか？見て楽しいんだから
なぜいろんな音を聞いてるんですか？聞いて楽しいんだから
なんでご飯食べてるんですかと
食べて楽しいんだから
なんで運動したりいろんなことやってますか？そういうことをして楽しいんだから
そういういろんなことをして楽しみを味わおうではないかと
楽しさを味わおうではないかと
そういう心の希望があるんです
と言っても心がいません
それは目の方はこの機能で
そこで何かを体感げたいんですね
体感という言葉でいいんですね
いわゆるこの体感中心に体感求めて
心の心という機能が機能しているんだと
そこで我々人を支配したい時は
人をコントロールしたい時は
いつでもこの快感論でやっちゃうんですね
なんとかもう快感で本当に快感を与えてくれませんだけど
もう快感ありますよと嘘でも言うんですね
例えば物は売りたい時でも
本当は人は買いたくない
そこでまあ 20万円ぐらい値札をつけちゃって
この今月から 1ヶ月間以内は 50%割引と言っちゃうんです
買い物の価値だと そうすると買っちゃうんですね
その時も快感売ってる
どんな快感というと  10万円儲かったという快感
あれは真っ平な嘘なんです
10万円払ったのに 払ってどうでもいいものを買ったのに
やっぱりさっさと行って買っても 10万円儲かったと
よく人間それで生きてるんですよと思いますけど
そんな嘘の世界で そこにも使っているのは快感論なんですね
ですから この なんでこの子供たちがこの勉強するのは嫌ですかというと
大人が忘れちゃうんですね
この自分の世界から考えても
この快感論という この戦えと
そうすると嫌になっちゃう
やっぱり心は正直だから
嫌なものはやりたくないんです
ですから このこれをうまく使えば
どんな怠けな怠け子供であろうとも
もうしっかり勉強させることはできるんです
それ 快感の方を目覚めてあげれば
快感なくてもいいんです
あのバーゲンと同じく
で 儲かったと思っちゃうんだから
これあれはすごい面白いよと
難しい算数のことやって
こうやってすごい面白い
面白いよとかね でまあバカみたいに楽しむ楽しがってあげれば
自分も楽しくなって 相手もすごくできたんですね
すごいああだこうだとか
あれもっと早くできる
もっとすごいよと言っちゃうと
あ なんか面白いだなと心がすごく理解しちゃうんですね
それでもうくだらない勉強でもしちゃうんです
ですから この僕はよく出す例は山登りなんですね
登山家の例なんですね
すごいきついことなんです
あれは 命懸けもちょっとしたことで死ぬんですけど
でも訓練して訓練して
ありとあらゆることをして
やっぱり山を登る 何があるかと
何にもない 登ることも苦しい
すごいきつい条件の中でとにかく登る
登って登ってから下りると
なんであんなバカなことをやるんですかと
その人 山の頂上まで登ったんだから
人類の救い主になったわけではないし
経済日本の経済状態は良くなったわけではないし
新しい人間に必要なものを発展したわけでもないし
破壊しつつする汚染層がもう治りかけるわけでもないし
何の役にも立たないんです
それでその人はすごい体力つけますからと言ったっても
どうせ私たちと同じく年取って老化して死ぬんだから
いくら体力あったっても
年取っちゃったらもうみんな同じくもう
ですから結局運動しても損しただけのことなんです
運動してよく健康な体で損しましたというところで終わっちゃいますけど
それでもやるでしょうね
人間っていうのは あれどこかで快感あるんですね
実際にあるかというと全然ないんです
酸素はないし寒いし それであの何て言いますか
あれ背負って酸素を補給しながら
で すごい寒くて で 小さなテント張って
そこで美味しいものは食べられるわけじゃないし
で 持っていた何とか何とか食べてとかね
お風呂には入れませんし
で 何が快感ですかと やったぞという快感なんですね
それだったら夢見て夢でヒマラヤ山脈登ったって同じことなんですけど
やっぱりそういう快感というのは
こういう快感論使い捕まれば
人間どんなバカなことでもするんです
ですから 我々は操られているのはこの快感論なんですね
どうしようもないんで
心は楽しみたいんだから
どうしようもないんです
ですから 僕ら仏教の立場から言うならば
もうちょっと気をつけなさいと気をつけて
まあ楽しみたいのは別にまあしょうがないんだと
あんた方は だからくだらないことをしないで
本物の楽しみを探し求めて生きなさいということなんです
だからこの二十万円の品物は
このもう新発売だから一ヶ月
二ヶ月の間だけ五十パーセント割引
そこで言ってバカみたいと買うんじゃなくて
ものは必要かないか 役に立つか立たないかと
十万円払っちゃいますから
その価値があるかないかと
それを買ったところで楽しいかないかと計算してからやった方がいいということなんですね
男性の方々っていうのは
すぐ見ただけであの人は綺麗やと思ってもう結婚しちゃうのよ
後でもう後の祭りなんですけど
そうじゃなくて ただ見ただけですぐ綺麗や美人やと思う
そこで決めるんじゃなくて
まあ自分と一生一緒に生きていられるぐらいの性格はぴったし合うか合わないかとか
それもちょっと考え直した方がいいし
そうすると失敗がないんですね
失敗少ないんですね すぐ快感だと言って飛ぶなと
せっかくの快感も消えちゃいますから
ただ 仏教では酒におぼれるなと
もう酒やめなさいと いい加減
ちょっとだけいいんじゃないかと
そんな甘えるんじゃないんだと
酒はもう依存するものだと
物事っていうのは ここまでこれぐらいやれば満腹満足やっていうことはないんですね
ご飯にはあるんですよ
お腹にもう入らないところになっちゃったら
もうこれで終わりますからね
で それで血液に糖分が入っちゃったら
脳細胞は活動して もうこれでやめなさいと言ってくるんです
酒の場合はそれはないんです
ですからいい加減やめなさいと
なぜかというと せっかくの人生の楽しさ消えちゃうんですね
病気になったりとか そういう風にそんなに楽しみければ
健康な体であまり欲少なくして
余計な欲なく 知足 小欲知足で明るく気楽にやりなさいと
そうすると死ぬ瞬間まで楽しいと
そこで確固たる楽しみ論を教えてあるんです
そこでこのこのくだらない
このくだらないというのは失礼な言葉なんですが
後でこの仏教は宗教になってくると
もういろんな話をして
この念仏を唱えれば この呪文を唱えれば
このお経を唱えれば これぐらい徳があるんだとか
限りない欲を作っちゃうんですね
それでもうすごい苦労するんです
朝から晩まで 1万回唱えなくちゃいけないんだとか
1万回唱えたっても もう全く何にもないんです
ご苦労様ですだけですけどね
お釈迦様はそんなこと言わないんです
小欲知足で仲良く みんなと喧嘩しないで
自分の義務はそれなりに果たして
ごく普通に生きてみてくださいと
で それは心が楽しみを
何て言いますか 希望してるんだから
もうしょうがないんです
そこでせっかく自分が子供を作ったならば
子供と楽しめばいいんです
そこで余計な欲付いちゃうんですね
この子は世界一流の人間にしてあげますとか
一流の教育をしてあげますとか
行って子供をいじめる
自分もいじめる 親も父親ももういっぱい仕事して子供のために頑張らなくてとか
自分をいじめる 子供をいじめる
遊ぶ暇がないんだから
子供と そういうこんなこの希望だけの妄想だけの欲なんか置いておいて
そこでせっかくの楽しみ消えますから
ほどほどにまあそこそこのところで子供とも遊んだりして
まあ子供の悩んでる時はそれは何とかしたりとか
子供のなんか問題かかっているとか
どうですかああですかとか
まあ一緒になって考えてあげたりとか
そこで仲間を子供をいい仲間にして
二人とも成長すると それはもうすごい幸福なんですね
この神 今の父親っていうのはそんなに怖いものではないんだけど
もういい子供のいい仲間になって
母親も子供のいい話し相手になって
いろいろディスカッションしながら
そうですね ああですねとか
そういう風になってくると楽しいし
そこに余計な欲が入っちゃうと地獄になってしまいますよ
そこで心の特色はそういう特色があります
とにかくこの快感 楽しみたいと
そういうことで人間が必死で行動している
人間の人生は 例えば人間の文化は一言で説明してください
一つ一つの言葉で なぜ人間は文化を作るんですか？ありとあらゆるところで
科学文化も他の文化も全部まとめて
すごい簡単でしょ 楽しむためなんです
じゃあ文化作って楽しいんですかね
結局は 結局もう人間っていうのは本当にもうかわいそうなアホだから
その文化によって苦しんでるんですね
いろんなしきたり作るは
これこの会社ではこうだこうだ
あの社会ではああだこうだとか
こうしてはいけない ああしてはいけないとか
まあいっぱいありまして
結局苦しいんです たとえ私のたとえ話はあまりたくさんないんだけど
結婚式ってのは大変楽しいところだけど
みんな緊張して緊張して
だから結婚式ってのはすごい文化的な行事なのに
服装について緊張するわ
お化粧についてすごい緊張するわ
もう祝電って何て言いますか
そのことについてすごい緊張するわ
もう結局面白くない祭りになってしまっちゃうんですね
緊張ばっかりして そこは楽しいんですかね
本当に だからそれもあるんですね
心はそんなに楽しければきちんと楽しめと
それはなし で おかしくなるんです
次の心の特色は怒り パーリ語の言葉はドーサと読むんですね DOSA
で このドーサ 怒りというのも
この楽しみさから生まれるんです
いわゆる自己愛から生まれるんです
自己愛という化け物がいて
自己という化け物は完全に化け物なんですね
化け物が作っちゃって
妄想概念 それに自己愛というものが生まれてきて
それによって我々は快感論を作っちゃって楽しもうとする
そこでどうせ人間というのは屁理屈の塊だから
せっかくの楽しみさを壊しちゃうんですね
無茶苦茶にしちゃうんですね
それはもう馬鹿だからなんですが
そこで希望通りにいかないでしょ
そこで怒る すごい簡単なこの順番でそうなってしまっちゃうんですね
いわゆる自分の希望通りに物事はいかないと怒ってしまう
怒りの解釈はただそれだけ
希望通りに物事はいくと怒りません
でしょう どんな鬼親でも
子供はきちんと勉強して
きちんと行儀よく頑張ってくると絶対怒りませんだから
そうすると親がすごいこの誤解するんです
自分がすごく落ち着いているんだと
子供には一度も怒ったことがないんだと
そういうバカ自慢するお母さんたちがいるんです
あれは嘘です あれは子供はもう立派だからなんですね
それだったら あんたそれだったら子供に礼をしなさいと
頭下げてありがとうございますとおかげさまで怒ることはなかったと
別に人間に怒りがなくなったわけじゃないんです
それ説明するためにすごい面白いエピソードをお釈迦様の時代で起きたんです
で あるこのお金持ちの家がいて
その家のおかみさんですか
この奥様がもう大体この奥さんたちっていうのは
この召使いの人々に対してはすごいきつく当たるということは何かあったみたいですね
そこでこのその人に一人の女の人がお手伝いさんとして
昔は召使いだからね 召使いの女の子一人がいたんです
女の子人が そこでこの奥さんの話は国中広げてるんです
あれ 素晴らしい奥さんだと
一度も自分の召使いに怒ったことはないんだと
叱ったことはないんだと
なんか自分の召使いなのに
なんか兄弟みたいにニコニコと喋ったりとか
いろいろことを話したりとか
もうすごいんだと この国ではそんなに落ち着いている
そんなにできている奥さんは一人もいませんと
あまりも人気なんです
そこでこの召使いの人が
女の人があっちこっち行くと
いつでもこの自分の主人の誉め言葉しかもう耳に入らないんですね
あなたいいですね 立派な人のところに召使いになって
我々他のこの召使い同士にしたっても
みんな殴られるわいじめられるわ
ろくなご飯ろくにご飯食べさせないわ
もう苦しみばっかりなんですね
奴隷扱いされちゃって
そこでみんな羨ましがってるんですね
あなたは本当にいいですね
幸福ですね ああだこうだとか
あんなに立派な人のところにいるんだからといて
この女の人はある日考えちゃって
あれなんでしょうかね
こんなことは 本当にあの人は落ち着いてるんですかと
自分の主人というか 主人というのはこの奥さんのことをでしたけど
おそらく私は一度もミスをしたことがないでしょうし
失敗したことはないし
もしかすると私は立派に仕事をしているんだから
怒る機会がなかったのではないかと
本当の心の状態はわかったもんじゃないんだと思って
悪いことにこの召使いの人はこの外へいつでも出ますから
よく仏教のお坊さんたちに会ったり
お釈迦様にも会ったりした経験があるんです
会って仏教を知ってるんですね
ですから もう何でも試してみるという
とんでもない性格ついてるんです
信じはしません 試してみる
じゃあ試してみると ありえないんだ
そんなもうもう心ってのは怒らないっていうこと
言って で 夜寝る 次の日はもう朝随分早く起きなくちゃいけないんですね
彼女はちょっと朝寝坊したんです
わざと そこで奥さんが起きてみたところで
普通の日起きちゃったら1,000万
準備して用意しているあるんですね
うちで仕事は掃除して終わって
台所の用意終わったりとかね
いろいろ儀式あるでしょうね
起きたんだけど何もない
じゃあ召使いの方を見たらもう寝てるんですね
そこで起こしたんですね
起きなさいと まだ寝てるんですかと
起きてて召使いの人は起きなさいって言ったらちょっと顔見たんですね
やっぱり顔に怒りがあったんですね
そこでやっぱり怒りがあるんだ
この人 別に落ち着いてるわけじゃないんだと決めて
それで足らないんですね
次の日も試しに試してみると
次の日も朝寝坊したんです
2日目 朝寝坊ということは
1日目はまだ起きなさいと言われただけなんですね
2日も あんた何ですかね
もう 朝寝坊して召使いの身分でと怒って叱っちゃったんです
で やっぱりともっと試しますと
で  3日目も朝寝坊したんです
そこであの奥さんがカンカン怒っちゃって
ドアにドア止めるためにこの大きな
なんて言いますか かんぬきですか
大きなものあるんで 木に作っているこのあれ
野球バットみたいな 結構大きいものあるんですね
それがあるんだから それ持ってきてもうぶん殴っちゃったんです
起きなさいと 言ったらこれ怪我するでしょうに
そしたら怪我した 血が流れたんです
そこであの召使いの人は何のこともなく起きて街に行ったんです
街に行ってみんなに大きな声で見てくださいと
あなた方はよく褒めている奥さんのやり方
私はちょっと朝寝坊しただけですよと
ほんのちょっと 別にものを壊したわけでもないし
うちのものを盗んだわけでもないんだと
料理失敗したわけでもないんだと
ちょっと朝寝坊しただけですよと
この様ですよと で その日からあの奥さんの悪口ばっかり一日言われるようになったんだと
で で そういうエピソードがあって
ということは もう彼女はやっぱりあの奥さんに一つ教えてあげたんですね
自分の身をもって あなたは威張るなと
高慢するなと 私を落としめている立派な立派なお嬢様だと
冗談じゃないんだと あなたもただの人間で
他の人々と同じ人間だと
物事は希望通りにいかないと
あなたもただの悪人そのものだよということはもうきちんと教えてあげただけのこと
で そのストーリーをもってお釈迦様ももう物事はうまくいくと
人間は怒らないんですが
ちょっと物事うまくいかないと怒るんです
それは事実です それで我々には怒りの世界がありますね
いろんな怒りあります
気に入らないということも怒り
悔しいということも怒り
心暗くなることも怒り
人を批判することも怒り
この評論家とかいろいろいらっしゃるでしょうね
自分では作品作れませんだけど
偉い評論家になったりしたりとか
作品を作る人もものすごい苦しい中で頑張っちゃいますけど
何のこともしないで まあ食べ物の評論家とか
もう個人的にあまり好きじゃないことですけど
それはこっちのことどうでもいいんだけど
評論家になって人は料理作るのどれほど苦しいかとか
それは全然気にしない
食べてああだこうだとか
まあそういうあまり批判したくなるのは怒り
あまりにも世直し世直ししようとか
人直す直そうとか そんなものをよく見ればもう怒りなんです
で そういういろんな怒りがある
嫉妬も怒り 妬みも怒り
競争したがるのことも怒り
ですから 嫌になることから
もう全ては怒り あの怒りというのは気持ちがこの楽しみたいですよ
心が 楽しみたいんだから
ちょっと楽しくないなと思った瞬間からもう怒りなんですね
あ これは楽しくないんだと
これはちょっと嫌だと思う
その瞬間から怒り それも心の悪い我々の苦しみを作ってくれる特色でございますので
皆様にも どんな人間にも
どんな生命にもあるんです
もう私だけいいわと思うのもちょっとあの
自己満足に陥ってはいけないんです
気をつけた方がいいんです
どんな人の心の中にも恐ろしい悪魔の性質が宿っているんです
生きてる仏様たちじゃないんです
生きている鬼たちなんです
仏教ではみんななんていうんですか
衆生みんな仏性ありや
みんなブッダ お釈迦様
如来や あだこだと言って
まあそれは完全なる嘘を言ってますが
この立場から言えば そうじゃなくて
まあ事実言えばみんな生きてる鬼たちですねとかね
だからちょっといじったら鬼は出てきますからね
ちょっといじったらもうポーンと出ますからね
人は本来仏性あって仏様であるならば
人はいじめるとこの殻を破って
本来の素晴らしい仏様が現れるはずなんですね
どうなるんですか？我々の心をいじめてみると
ちょっといじってみると鬼が出ちゃうんですね
悪魔が ですからこの どんな人をも簡単に殺人者にしてあげることができるんです
ちょっともういじめてやれば
それでも出ちゃうんですから
ですから この自分のこの希望通りに物事を行かないと怒るということを
一つの我々の生き方の特色であって
そこで 3番目は無破というんです
それをこの あの この知と書く
書くんです あの あの知恵がない
あの あの 何ですかね あの無知の無知という意味で
あの知恵の知じゃないんです
あの愚か者という頭の悪いという
あの山平というんですか
あの それに知るという字を埋め込めば
その知は病気だという
仏教の無破っていうのは
なんかすごく可愛い言葉なんです
なんかガキみたいな まあ子供みたいに何も知らないということで
それ心のまた特色なんですね
ですから 我々はもうアホでバカでいることは
心のごく普通の特色なんです
ですから 私はよく仏教の話をよく言うんですね
愚か者とか だから別に怒る必要ないんです
それはごく普通なことなんです
皆様 あなた方は日本人でしょう
と言ったら怒りますか？怒らないでしょ
当たり前のことを言ってるんだから
ですから 別に怒る必要ないんです
で この無知というのは本当にバカなんですね
例えば楽しみたいでしょ
楽しみたいのに楽しめないんですね
人生を苦しくしちゃうんですね
楽しみたければ もうなんだかんだも楽しみの方向へ持っていけばいいでしょう
仕事は楽しみにしちゃう
勉強も楽しみにする 料理をすることも楽しみにする
これをなんだかんだも片っ端から楽しみにすればいいのに
全部苦しいでしょうね
全部苦しいんです たとえ遊びは
楽しみのものですけど
それも地獄の苦しみにしてるんですね
スポーツとかなんとか作っちゃって
いろんな大会とか作っちゃって
それでプロのなんとか何とかしたりして
全然楽しくも何にもないんです
あれ命かけてやらなくちゃいけないんです
例えば野球選手であろうが
ちょっとボール一つミスしたったら
あれすごいショックなんです
あ 滑っちゃったというふうに楽しむことできませんよ
あれはもう点数に入っちゃいますから
それで次の何て言いますか
この給料でもう何百万もなくなっちゃいますから
あっち何が楽しいんですかね
そうすると命かけなくちゃいけない
あのくだらない球を捕まることに
ですから 全くくだらないことだから
もう馬鹿げたく遊んでやればいいのに
人間はそうはいかないんです
それはもうスポーツにするんですね
それで苦しみなんですね
もうお金いくらか儲けて
みんなを助けてあげて
みんなにいいことをしてあげて
してあげて それでいくらかお金儲けて
自分もそれでご飯食べて楽しく家族を養っていたいのに
仕事はすごい苦しみでしちゃうんですね
なんでそんなことをするんですかね
ちょっと理屈ちょっと合理的に利己的に考えればできることでしょうに
なんでそれないんですかね
たとえ旅行にしたって旅行に行ったっても
まあ何時何分で出発して
何時何分でああだこうだとか決めちゃって
そこでこれこのこちらのもうこれを 33 分で見てくださいとか
それでもう旗を持ってまあおかしい
でもおかしいんですね
何も楽しみがないと思いますよ
まあまあどうかわかりませんだけど
団体旅行の場合は あれ安全というぐらいのことかなと思いますけどね
何でもシステム化しちゃって
それにシステムにはめられて
では大変だ 大変ストレスかかってるんですね
例えば自由時間が 1時間ありますよと
買い物してくださいと
と外国旅行して そこで時計見ながら
これあまり外国語も喋れないし
これこれこれもあれも嫌と言ってるもう時間行っちゃって
そこでまた走って もう集合場所に行かなくちゃいけない
何の楽しみもないんですね
やっぱり やっぱり人間は本当にバカなんです
何でもこのせっかく楽しめるものをさえ苦しみの設定にする
学校で同じ年の同じ気持ち理解できる仲間がいっぱいいて
最高に楽しいなのに 学校の勉強はライバル意識でやってるんですね
敵ばっかしでしょうに
そうすると 考えるぞっとするほど苦しい世界なんですね
そういうのを作るこんなもの
心のこの愚かさ ヘリクツさ
非合理的さ それに盲目的ですね
そこでおかしいことは
純然純粋たるヘリクツで非合理的であるにも関わらず
人間が自分たちがすごい合理的だとよく言うんです
合理的なのはもう質素な言い方ですが
釈尊の言葉だけなんです
皆様方はどなたであろうか
あのやっぱり私 前も言いましたからね
あの人は死んでも楽しい
霊魂は死にませんと なんか映画の世界に何か一人の方がいるみたいですね
この霊界とか何とか言って
ああいう話は気持ちいいんですね
その本人も もうえらい
この何て言いますか 自分の妄想界に酔ってしまって
楽しくはいるんで 楽しくいることは大変いいことですけど
もうやっぱり結局自分を酔ってるんですね
永遠な霊界がある すごい楽しい世界あるんだと死んでも
そこはもうすごい そういうふうなこと言われると楽しいんです
それはヘリクツなんです
ですから 結局心っていうのはそういうちょっとしたことで騙されやすい
騙しやすい もうだから基本は無知なんです
知なんです 心の基本 じゃあこれは心の悪い方向だけ今日私は説明しましたけど
悪い方向だけ またいい部分もあります
でも我々の生き方では
例えば 24時間生きてると
この労動 動作 謀反で生きてる時間というのは大体まあ 23時間とまあ 50 分ぐらいかな
残り 10 分はもしかするといい明るい心でいるかもしれません
ほんのかすかな すごい暗い心でやられているんです
そこでこの危ないのは
この体は体の主 体の親が心なんです
体はただの物体ですから動かないんです
指一本も動かないんです
心がなければ 私はこうやったんだけど
こうやって指を動かすこともできるし
こうやって指を動かすこともできるんだけど
それ心の違いでしょ 心がこうやって動かしたい場合はこう動かしちゃうし
左手で動かしたい場合はこうやっちゃうし
心なんですね ですから
この心は体も支配して全て支配しているんだから
その心はものすごい汚くて悪いもので
頭の悪い大馬鹿者であるならば
人間は幸福になりますか？なりっこないんです
だから 主人が大馬鹿者で悪しき者で
屁理屈で何が正しいかと全くわからなくて無茶苦茶だったら
家はもう決まったもんでしょ
結果は ですから 私個人の場合も同じでということを考えてください
私の心が大馬鹿者で 怒りやら貪りやら無知やらそれで支配されていて行動しているんだと
だから結局は不幸になってしまっちゃうんだと
それで人間のこの作っているものを見ると同じことでしょ
いくら薬作っても病気は消えないし
薬の数だけは増えちゃうし
結局我々は病気はそのままで薬を飲むとまた違うことが出ているし
科学は発展して幸福になっていくのはいいんだけど
同時にものすごく破壊
せっかく生きる土台は破壊していくんですね
で いろんなことそんなもんなんですね
教育システムはどんどん成長するのはいいんだけど
結局人間はダメになっちゃうんですね
あまりにも勉強しなくちゃいけないもの
あまりにもありすぎて
何をするべきかとわからなくなっちゃって
自分を見失ってしまっちゃうんですね
私は何で何者かとわからなくなっちゃうんです
自己コントロールできなくなっちゃう
結局結果としては好ましくない結果なんですね
そうでしょうね 事実は
で 世界一流の教育システムは日本にある
それだったら世界一流の結果を出すはずなんですけど
日本でも子供たちが自殺する
外国では自殺しない 殺されるかもしれませんだけど
誰かに 学校だからアメリカの学校だったら
たまにどんな学校でもないんだけど
まあ学校に入る前にこのボディをチェックして
拳銃とか持ってるかないかとか
まあそういうことはあるかもしれませんが
自殺する 自殺するということは
もう大変に責められた時でしょう
殺されるのはもうそんな大したことないんです
たまたま人が拳銃を持っていて殺されちゃっただけのことだから
そんなに精神的なショック受ける必要はないんです
でも 自分で自分を殺す場合は
やっぱりせっかく日本のお父様たちがお母様たちが一生懸命
考えて考えてありとあらゆる研究して
最高な教育システムを作ったのに
そういうふうなケースも出てくる
あれほど学校できちんと科学的にちゃんと教えているのに
落ちこぼれがいっぱい出るし
だから結局人間が貪瞋痴で全てしているんだだからどこかでおかしい結果なんですね
どこかで結果おかしい
だからといって別に自己嫌悪になる必要はないんで
そんなもんなんです そんなもんなんです
天国は作れませんよ 天国というか
楽園 地上の楽園は作れません
貪瞋痴ある限りは ということで
それは悪い方向の心の特色
それで体も同じなんです
体も病気になったり 癌になったり
ありとあらゆる痴呆になったりするのも
この貪瞋痴のせいなんです
だからもう何か物事をすぐ信じないで試せなきゃもうイライラするような性格があったら
まあ私もボケる可能性はありますけど
それはわかりませんですけど
まあもちろんかもしれませんしね
いくらかは ですから この知恵を使ってほしい
合理的になってほしい
きちんと楽しみを味わってほしい
楽しもうと思って自分を壊すなと
一番わかりやすい例は麻薬なんですね
麻薬を使った瞬間ではもう最高に幸福だそうです
30分経ったところでもうすごい地獄そのものというふうなものなんです
ですから そんなもうそういうふうなことで自分を破壊しないで
きちんと考えて楽しみを味わえればいいんではないかなと
そこら辺 ここ次は心のいい方向と
そのままズルズルと心の育ち方に話を続けていきます
本当に時間が延びましたので
もう長い時間申し訳ないんですけど
どうもありがとうございました